it is my honor to present this remains
to you being able to hold that piece of
his body that he couldn't own for
himself will be able to treat it with
their respect and honor that is do that
we were gonna be able to give him the
burial that he deserves we're here
representing chanting generations before
us
we're just messenger
brethren I pray you sing a new song sing
praise in the Assembly of the righteous
thank you for forgiving him back to us
and for letting us take him home
lesbo God as only you can and continue
the legacy that you began with Reverend
that Turner I hope that people recognize
it for what it is a really significant
step in acknowledging a part of our
history that has been to a large degree
intentionally dismiss having this piece
of NAT Turner's body to bury
and the treat as a man is a huge
blessing for us because it will be
significant to all of those families who
don't have the buys of their ancestors
it's time to celebrate him and I cannot
wait for us to be as a you as a family
so we can do that
you know I I hope that he is looking
down and he I hope that he is proud of
us
individuals how many years out of
slavery are now owning oil wells that
are producing 2,000 barrels a day is
that not the ultimate American dream